josh holland
what's up what's up man thanks for
coming on the program
thanks for having me i'm excited to be
here i'm super duper pumped and grateful
to
shaker pie for making the introduction
shaker pie
everyone should know that name shakes
yeah shake and bake
shake your face shake and vape yeah yeah
he's i'm super grateful
for making the connection so yeah if
you're listening out there shake
in our um one person studio audience
thank you very much yes and what an epic
episode we have lined up
yeah we're gonna talk about curiosity
nunchi holistic wellness
all of the biohacking that's available
to us to optimize our health
so that we can achieve our north stars
more
efficiently so that we can become better
in partners to our to our intimate loved
ones to our children to our community
all this type of stuff i'm jacked all of
it
all of it all of it all of it i love it
now how did
josh holland become who he is today who
were you growing up what was your
journey like
so i um i grew up
in a small town in oklahoma called
chandler oklahoma
and uh i smile as i talk about chandler
because i
i loved my childhood and um
you know the the town is about 3 000
people so it's super small everybody
knows everyone
and you know it's like we we have people
that are called
nosy so like they want to be in your
business but it's because they also care
but also because they want to
be in your business right it's a good
way to have gossip
but if you can imagine growing up in a
place like that
i felt endless amounts of support and so
if i ever needed something
if i ever needed someone to talk to or
someone to
borrow money from or you know my car
broke down
there was always someone there which was
very interesting
um so i'm very very grateful to have the
childhood that i had
although i grew up very poor very poor
was on welfare
um you know just about as bad as it can
be
but i'm grateful to have experienced
that because
it now i see that when you do become
successful and you do have the means to
be able to
support yourself and a family and things
like that i'm
beyond grateful for it and you're
probably going to hear me say grateful
and gratitude quite a bit because
i am that yes yeah it's
probably one of the most powerful
feelings is gratitude and you can't
be grateful and angry at the same time
and
grateful and resentful at the same time
you you have
gratitude is such a strong powerful
emotion i'm wondering when you're
growing up
and you're having these instances of
noticing like that there's
you know welfare and that there's it's a
you know 3000 person city there's not
really
enough at times to sustain even at those
basic nutrient level
needs two things first is
how did you know that you wanted to
leave the small city and go out to what
was you know what was the intuitive
calling to leave to
see bigger things in the world and then
the other thing is would you say that
some of those
instances of not having those those
basic needs be met then
triggered a lot of the wisdoms that you
have today
in in seeing more abundance
great questions and i'll preface this by
saying um
i go on tangents in rabbit holes quite
easily
so be prepared okay good and uh
hopefully you can reel me back in but
i love the connection we've already made
and i love listening to your your your
shows that you put out there because
it seems easy to do that and it becomes
this beautiful
show um so if you're ready for this i'm
ready for it let's do it let's go um
all right so growing up
in my small town and then sort of what
led me to leaving
that town ultimately was this idea of
i i sensed that there was much more
there was much more for me to achieve
to to search for and curiosity is
probably the main
descriptive word that i could use for
myself
i've always been very very curious and
so
i knew that like okay i i know everyone
in my town
but then like when i travel to another
city or i travel to another town or i
travel out of state i'm like
well wait a minute maybe there's towns
like my towns in other states and what
about
parts of the world and you know every
time i watch a movie i see
new york city and i see la and i see
france i see other places
and i just felt like you know what i
want to get out of this city this little
town at some point
and so where did i go i went to oklahoma
city right so
after i graduated high school which is a
big deal for
from 3 000 person city to over a million
over a million yeah yeah so like 1.8
almost 2 million
um and so i what got me out of the town
was the curiosity
but it was also because i went to
college and that's almost like the
natural flow
especially where i'm from it's you grow
up
you you meet your loved one in high
school
you get married either before high
school finishes
or right out right as high school
finishes
and then you may go to college or you
start
a business and you support a family and
you get married and you have kids and
that's kind of the normal trajectory of
a person from my town
i was like like i i think when i set up
my first email
ever i had the email of going pro 22
because i knew 22 was my basketball
number so i
i after getting a black belt at the age
of 12
it was like there's that mosquito the
one the rabbit hole the one that bit you
a little bit
yeah yeah yeah rabbit hole but i'm
reeling it back
okay so i got a black belt at the age of
12.
it's so badass and we can talk about
that as well but
from bat from uh karate
or from getting a black belt to then
basketball i kind of realized that you
know what i want to
play professionally i want that to be my
calling right so
i chose the college that i went to based
on
being able to get a scholarship and so i
got an academic scholarship
and a athletic scholarship and then from
there i'm like wow this is what i want
to do i want to go pro and that was kind
of
what led me into understanding more
about
injuries and how to perform better which
is ultimately
what got me to where i am now
interesting i see it i see it
and i i had to and i'm making this a
full circle
yeah yeah answer because this is great i
had to choose a college in which
i i could go to for free because i
didn't have the money
to be able to to do that right and i saw
the example of my older brother
my brother mario is 364 days older than
i
am so we're irish black irish twins and
um
so we're one day out of every year we're
the same age which is kind of cool
um and it's impressive what my mom and
dad did and and having that occur
very interesting um so i saw my brother
as an example of
kind of what not to do in that
he chose a school that was a private
school that cost
money and so he had a small scholarship
as well
but it wasn't enough to cover all of it
obviously so
that put a burden on him and or my dad
and i saw that and i kind of said to
myself
and this is the first time i'm actually
publicly saying this but like
i said to myself at that moment i want
to do whatever i can to not allow
that to happen to put you know that kind
of burden on myself
and on my family yeah so i'm going to
choose i'm going to work my butt off i'm
going to play
the best that i can be the best that i
can be so that so that i can go to a
big school get it for free and
academically
you know so i actually made money going
to school because i had like these um
these other jobs like i was a tutor for
my basketball team
i worked at uh gnc general nutrition
center
so that's where i got all the extensive
knowledge of like supplements and stuff
you know
wow the dots are connecting i that's
interesting so much man
yeah so okay
interesting story also with mario your
older brother
and how you saw that you didn't want to
take on
a similar amount of financial
burden on yourself and your family but
that you're going to work your ass off
in order to get the
high level scholarships that you need
and it's interesting that you had
black belt by age 12 and then you had
this
point guard player in so in college ball
and then that led to also semi-pro ball
okay
and then gnc on this nutrition as well
yeah and
it's super interesting i can kind of see
it formulating
now the the essence of you
at this like kind of like early 20s
time period yeah yeah you know it's it
there's there's so many layers
to my journey but there's also so many
layers to all of our journeys right
and what led that journey was
constant curiosity yeah right so i'll
bring it back to the constant curiosity
because
i wasn't the guy that and again because
i grew up poor
this is reeling me back because i grew
up very poor
i vowed to never
need again in my life right and so
this is what ultimately shaped me into
the person that i am
very grateful for that because you know
if i didn't
experience the pain and you know in the
the
embarrassment of having to have food
stamps like to pull out food stamps when
my friends are pulling out
real money right for me i was i was
pulling out monopoly money
yeah it was very embarrassing right and
then they changed it to a card and then
you know
and it it just has this level of
embarrassment but it's what lit the fire
under under me to say
you know what josh is never going to be
there not that that's
you know a bad thing because it's what
shaped me but
i knew that i wanted to transcend that
and have that be
something that you know if i need to
support my family
i can do that and so you know the
curiosity
is what got me to go okay if i'm good at
basketball and i'm good at school
because you know there's an art to
school i felt like school was easy for
me
right which is interesting because
when we're forced to learn the way we're
forced to learn
not the way that i think really we
should learn i think we should just
evolve
into being thrust into nature being
thrust into work
being thrust into many different ideas
like we should be spending more time
with people who are doing the things
that we want to do
yeah in the real world since right again
we're going to rabbit hole in that
um but because i was curious
in fact i went to right around the time
that i got my black belt
i went to an entrepreneurial ship camp
at oklahoma state university
okay for two reasons okay at 12 years
old
why am i going you went to an
entrepreneur camp at age 12. oh yeah
that's interesting
yeah that's another cool aspect to this
connecting the dots got it right
okay so i got a chance to see my dad be
an entrepreneur
i learned what it was to be an
entrepreneur entrepreneur what was he
doing for
his entrepreneur so my dad was the chief
of police in my hometown
he was the head of emt he was a storm
chaser
he ran a karate school and he was a
plumber
a carpenter and a massage therapist all
in one yeah that's
very polymathic i love that yeah that's
great so this is what i grew up
that's great seeing and then i had my
mom who i also looked up to as well
you know the support when her my dad
divorced i i got a chance to also
witness
the strength within her the power within
her
to see all and experience all the things
that she had to go through
so she also was she was a brown belt in
uh in karate
yeah and you know she had to take on the
task of
of two growing young men
yearning for their father but also
having to like
support us and you know and she got in
and out of a couple abusive
relationships and
we witnessed that so my childhood
is what ultimately allows me to be very
empathetic to
other people that i work with so that
when some people look at me and say
oh but like of course you're fit because
you know you
you have good genes or you know because
you work out all the time and it's like
no you know like i am paddling up
upstream yeah you know i started with a
very
interesting childhood and i've i've kind
of worked through that
and i've allowed it to to be a part of
who i
am so that i can then draw lots of
different
perspectives i think it's all about
perspective yeah and as long as you're
curious enough
to to see something through the darkness
right then i know like on the other side
of it it has to be something beautiful
yes and yes you know now so i've gone
from
being an entrepreneur like when i was 12
i went to this camp to understand
first of all how to spell the word
second of all like what it truly means
and so when i got back from that camp i
said to my dad i'm like
i know what it is you do and you know
it's like i get it now
so i saw that my dad was having to put
so many
things together to get ends to meet to
take care of us
and i understood that at a very young
age it's like
all my friends would get allowances
all my friends would get you know to be
able to do all these different things
and i'm like
what yeah like an allowance are you
kidding me
like i was lucky enough to be able to
get new clothes for the next school year
yeah right so what did i do i i emulated
what i saw my dad doing
putting everything together to make ends
meet so i
mowed yards i raked leaves
i shoveled snow i had a government job
at age
14 when i was so i worked at uh
a subway subway sandwich shop at age 14
i was a sunday manager i was running the
store by myself
learning how to to balance out the
register
learning how to open clothes having the
responsibility of a kia 14 years old
yeah
right and this is because i had i saw my
dad doing this
i was already a black belt so i was at
this maturity level of
of having grown adults
bow to me bow to the studio the dojo
understanding that it wasn't even about
how old i was it was
the experience that i had within me at
such a young age and
to become a black belt in my dad's
karate system called the american karate
system
in order to have a black belt you have
to certify an anatomy and first aid
why because that's a part of his journey
yeah and so when he wanted to create
this
system he wanted everyone to experience
some of what he had to experience to get
to where he was
so anyway yeah there's so much we can
tell you man
there's it's again the dots are making
more sense especially
that you took on a a pretty serious
amount of responsibility at a young age
to do things like
in a sense you know mirror a lot of your
dad's polymothy like you saw that he was
going and drawing from a lot of
different fields you began doing that
yourself you took on responsibility at a
young age at a
managerial level you know the key
opening and closing the stores
you know this is the type of stuff that
sort of like you said it makes you
mature
quickly and it makes you realize that
you definitely want
something more beyond this in life you
want to go and achieve
more and i see also how it ended up
being kind of a synthesis
for you in terms of uh holistic
wellness as well drawing from all these
different fields
uh as you kind of went through your
later
on in your collegiate and uh and beyond
days
is that also kind of the birth of
wanting to do some of the
one-on-one training with people and
wanting to take what you've gathered and
then
personalized people was that kind of
like the time of the birth of it
and this definitely and this has been
the move to new york yeah it's
it's interesting and it's a really good
question i love the way you phrase it
because
it's i guess at some point
in my childhood i must have learned or
felt
this this immediate reward
of helping people and making people
happy
i couldn't i can't put a finger on
exactly when that was
but at some point i must have witnessed
my father taking care of people
because everyone in my town loves my my
dad and my mom
it was just that when she moved it
mostly was just my dad my dad stayed in
my hometown
he still lives there to this day
everyone because again
because of the small town mentality or
the idea of being in a small town
everyone already knew us but that could
be a good thing or a bad thing so
when i saw that people that i look up to
my dad and others when they make people
feel good
i saw i i experienced what i felt
in witnessing that and it's like well
that feels good to me to witness this
so what can i do to also
feel this more and have other people
feel that because surely there's more
people out there
like me that are feeling this right and
this is a very deep
i like the way you qui you asked a
question because it's it's
it's allowing me to talk about things
that i haven't talked about on other
shows
um and it's it's allowing me to be aware
of parts of my childhood that i maybe
hadn't been aware of because the
question hadn't been asked that way
also maybe you know um being elevated a
little bit
at this moment allows me to be very
introspective
which also ultimately leads me to the
the idea of my logo and things like that
which we'll talk about but
um seeing that i think is the first time
in my in my childhood is what got me to
say
whatever it is i do in life i want it to
always
make people feel good because it makes
me feel good
and then from there i started to see the
different routes
so me playing basketball in high school
at a high level me um
doing martial arts at a very high level
i got a chance to see the eastern
philosophy of things
so people who would be considered quacks
are people that i bow to yeah people
that i
call my grandmaster yeah and even to
this day i have
the utmost respect just because of what
it meant
to me in my childhood and to see them
work with
herbs and tinctures and topical
ointments and things like that
to heal people and to to literally
create chi in the palm of their hand and
help them
to heal people yeah caused me to go
wow again this is you're talking about a
curious person
who sees that yeah yeah maybe other
people they might go oh you know okay
cool
they either believe it or they don't but
for me i'm like
what's behind all of that teach me so
even though i wasn't a big fan of
reading then i'm a huge fan of reading
now
i still wanted to look at all the
magazines and watch the videos
and talk to people this is why i like to
talk this is why i like to have a
podcast show
this is why i like to come on to podcast
shows because
i know that there's so much more beyond
what a person's saying
you know you know and i use that in my
practice
at this very day yeah and i i learned
that from a very very young age because
of martial arts
but then because of basketball i learned
that
well in martial arts it's it's normal
standard to not heavy heavy weight train
because why
it's this idea of weights and bulkiness
slows you down
but when i started playing basketball i
started to see that wait a minute no
i'm actually doing much better in
basketball when i actually weight train
so then the curious person in me is like
so you're saying there's two sides maybe
to this
well maybe there's a third side maybe
there's 1200 signs right
so anyway yeah that's that i think it's
a long-winded answer to say that
interesting those are all variables yeah
yeah those are all variables yeah i see
that's a good way to that's a good great
way to put it there's like
for some reason there's like sometimes
an obsession with like a unidimensional
greatness and yeah it can be
it can be good to train a single
variable in depth
like you know becoming in
the world's best protocol designer in
the decentralization
movement or for the bioengineering with
all of the different
technologies like crispr cast 9 and
beyond that are evolving
if you're really really really good at
one of those things you can become kind
of like the world's best in that field
and that's great but a lot of the times
then you miss all of the
multivariability that actually goes into
play like
you can miss an interesting connection
between decentralization and biology
and you can miss an interesting
connection between actually
lifting weights and how that actually
can enhance uh what would be
deemed as like a lean performance style
sport
uh or how meditation or nutrition or
sleep
or the spiritual mystic traditions
or biohacking effects also
all different aspects of life business
success all this type of stuff
and so this is a massive principle of
our program is
to be very polymathic in that sense to
drive home some of these
uh these unique synthetic perspectives
that end up
augmenting many different aspects of our
lives
and so that also begins to make sense i
want to see if this if this
sort of i also want to say one more
thing before i ask this question which
is that
another big part of the show is to give
these runways to people
so that people can dig into their
journeys and their north stars and their
passions and their
essence as a soul and unleash it in ways
that maybe they haven't before
and in ways that we can help be a
conducive container to that
flourishing it's critical and i hope
that with your podcast and all the other
ones that are currently occurring around
the world
to make basically that as one of the one
of the points
of the programs is to enable that unique
flowering
um of the guest to share their wisdom
and
and
for their both for themselves for the
for the interviewer and the
the audience as well then my question
would be that
you know as we look at
as we look at kind of like you know some
of these
some of these main fields you know
fitness health nutrition wellness
and also the biohacking component
the meditation component the
athletic component the sleep component
all this type of stuff
did you see you know as you're kind of
moving you know you're getting involved
in the space you're moving to new york
picking up work with clients you can
tell us about the journey aspect to that
as well but
did you see it kind of like we love
talking about patterns
right and you kind of see it like
patterns like this specific person
is this specific unique soul and they
have their specific
patterns that they have with their
family and their relationships with
their activities and habits
and their north star what they're
pursuing and then you kind of come in
as like someone that does a like a data
visualization of
who they are and what they're doing and
then you kind of
help with all of these different fields
fitness health nutrition wellness
patterns
that enhance them augment them is that
about right
spot on man i mean it's
at the end of the day optimization it's
it's um
helping people become aware of
who they are truly who they are based on
what they do
and i have a mantra that i i go by i
live by
that is our bodies and minds adapt to
what we do most of the time
yeah if you want to change your body and
mind you must change what it is you do
most of the time
that's beautiful and so when you take
that as a an awareness piece
i have to also understand that i i guess
going back to one of the first questions
you asked which is what led me to leave
the small town it was this very idea of
i want to do much more in life
and it was expected to to do life a
certain way and then you have one thing
you focus on
i've had many people throughout my
career even to this day
josh you need to focus on one thing
you're either an actor you're
either a model you're either an athlete
you're either
a trainer you can't be a trainer i mean
even the loss as in new york you can't
be a trainer
or you know yeah you can't be certain
practitioner and be a trainer at the
same time
or you know you in in some fields like
an acting you can't be a manager and an
agent you know
it's like all these limitations that are
embedded into our society
that i resist wholeheartedly
and whether i'm conscious of that or i
just
feel that it's innate within me it's
like
why not like if you always ask yourself
and you ask others why
in fact one of my one of my biggest
influences in this world of
quote-unquote celebrity training is
madonna
and she's one person that made me
understand the power of
why and there's a book out there right
the the power
i think it's called the power of why
right and start with why simon says
start with
as well right um i didn't read those
books
but i felt that from from a person as
iconic as madonna
that's great so when you ask yourself
why
then then it's like well why not why
shouldn't i
learn as much as i can learn about
nutrition
in fact not even just nutrition as an
umbrella but like
the eastern philosophy yeah the western
philosophy
the african philosophies right there's
many different
things out there and so if you can
imagine my curiosity there
well okay some people eat everything
omnivores some people only eat plants
and vegetarians it's like well what is
that about well what is gluten-free
about
what is keto about now you you take this
subsection
you take this this idea of nutrition and
it branches off into all these other
things
which again comes back to this branching
out of the logo
and but then coming back to the self
which is the
x that marks the spot right in the
middle of it right so
this is the journey it's like it's a
labyrinth
that sort of um
symbolizes the journey in which one has
to make and there's many different turns
and many different
things that get you ultimately to the to
the spot
which is in the center right you as the
center the self
so self reflection and also you could
you could say that the fact that it's
symmetrical right down the middle
is that it's reflective right so yeah
there's all these layers to it
but because we all have layers and my
journey has been a layering
effect and it's still layering meeting
you
talking to you today on this very day in
the middle
of a pandemic and all these things we're
all adding layers to ourselves
because we're forced to do things that
we never thought we'd have to do
so again that just kind of goes back to
this idea of
i want to be and we were talking about
this with shaker before we started the
show today
about how what would i call myself you
know what do we want to call me and we
we started to come up with this idea
of multi-modular yeah and i like that
because
i want people when they work with josh
when they work with me
they work with me because they see that
there's many different layers to him
because i i purposefully didn't want to
be
pigeonholed in and limited to
oh well josh is just a trainer so we're
gonna have to get someone else
why does that matter well one going back
to the whole idea of
not having money if i can help
service a person in many different
aspects
then maybe they don't have to go and pay
a nutritionist maybe they don't have to
go and pay a chef
maybe they don't have to hire a sleep
coach a therapist
not to say i am those things but i have
enough experience
totally yeah so i love that yeah you you
when you hit the most in this idea that
you
keep saying is that like you're in
service to other people and i love that
that's
that's this transitory we're moving away
from
focusing on solely the service to
self-self-dealing
architectures and and phenomenological
states of consciousness to
service to other states and finding the
beauty and the meaning and the love and
appreciation in that and that's been
something that you've been mentioning
throughout
this love for serving others and having
that make you feel good and
what you're doing is you're also you're
targeting something upstream for them
because the more upstream of something
that you target for them
the more all of the downstream kind of
lines up really well with their health
and so then they don't need all these
other multi thousand dollar investments
into different categories of health and
wellness
if you're already smart enough to go all
the way upstream and help them in that
regard
and they recognize that about you and
about the way you see things and the
patterns that
i'm talking about so you you started
sort of
picking up more and more clients and
working with them
new york now i think it was was it
like 16 years out there or something
like it was it was it that long
16 years 16 years out there yeah and she
just moved to l.a
re this year uh i still have my place
clear place in new york too
because you have your place and you have
you opened uh a
fitness center in the as well as a
holistic center in
in um flat iron districts so so
um yeah so then like
this has been the general idea of
working with
clients identifying the patterns
doing that in new york finding over time
being drawn more and more through
especially kind of like recommendations
to higher and higher places of
prominence because people
you know they respect you know when you
have some
issue with that needs neurology
neuroscientist uh neurosurgeon like
like i want who's at the top of the
hierarchy there like who knows the most
from the
most different fields and so that's why
they're you know
called up the most and paid the most and
so that's why you're kind of you kind of
got drawn up more to the celebrity folk
because they saw that more and more that
that was kind of your thing
so that kind of started for you around
that new york time and then
yeah okay yeah walk us through some of
this yeah
something i definitely think is uh worth
mentioning
is we
when you mentioned looking into the
patterns and
and the essence of different people and
helping them on their journey and then
the trickle-down effect
that ultimately ultimately helps them is
why i created
my five pillars for optimum health and
wellness
and the five pillars of optimum health
and wellness
are they um over on the
they may be then like it might be
i don't know if i listed it there are
they on instagram are they on
no i don't know i don't know i have done
it on my podcast
i have i have listed each of them on my
podcast like a separate
separate uh theme episodes i see okay
okay
but it's it's been um interesting
because
this is what i use as like a a blueprint
for how i work with people and so that
blueprint and i'll just rattle through
them quickly and then we can expand upon
those or we can move on to something
else if you want but let's do it i love
these
it's it's really cool because for
about for several years
when i first decided i wanted to come up
with a template to work with
people from a holistic perspective a
multi-modular
perspective i knew that i needed to
create a platform
in which i could sort of
use for each individual client
and for myself to then also reflect
back and draw back on time after time
after time
so it for for a while crucial
yes it's just like what i did with high
level perception publishing the project
it
ends up being this like 10 chapter
framework yes that you can kind of
have as a lattice work right and that's
why you have your pillars
that we're going to go through exactly
it's a very common theme that i've
noticed with people is that they kind of
like sponge up
all of this really beautiful especially
like higher level visionary people
sponge up all this great
knowledge information and then they like
wring it out in their own like
lattice work of ideas that they can
constantly reference and keep updating
i love this let's let's do this i love
it
are you about to you're going to use the
we're going to use the the
we're going to the ball camera yeah yeah
yeah that over the shoulder shot that
has a little bit of uh
some of our yeah yeah okay so
um the the five pillars for optimum
health and wellness
all have a a distinctive uh
word in front of each of the pillars and
that distinctive word is
quality so the five pillars start with
quality awareness and
i love that that's the first one yeah
well it's interesting because
that's where i was kind of going with
earlier is that's the most upstream
thing
yeah exactly so there's a prioritization
and
for for many years i only had four
pillars
until i started um chatting with my good
friend
celine who you recently met yeah and um
he was telling me about some of dr joe
dispenza's work that's right
and you know i i've i've dabbled into
meditation and all sorts of things and
and i i've
done some neural feedback and things
like that and so
it wasn't until i read dr joe dispenza's
book i forget the name of it um
the uh becoming supernatural becoming
supernatural when reading that
some things started to click yeah and
then i got a muse headband
and i started doing some other neural
feedback stuff and i'm like wait a
minute this
this is what meditation is all about wow
this is very powerful
well i kept start sort of like
feeling this sense of like i need to add
something else to my pillars
because there's some things that i keep
talking about and i keep experiencing
that
didn't quite fall into the other pillars
so
that's when i came up with the most
upstream one which is
quality awareness it quickly went to the
top so basically the idea is that
the five pillars are designed to work as
a trickle-down effect but becomes also
very circular
yes very yin and yang very you know in
the way that
nature works i mean everything is a
we're a unified field
you know my effect with someone else
selfishly also helps me feel very good
but also helps the unified field right
yes we can go very deep with that
yes um but number one is quality
awareness
yes okay within that includes meditation
self-reflection just understanding who
you are
at the at this center yeah okay um
number two
is quality sleep and recovery
and for the longest time remember that
was my first
pillar and it was because it was the
first thing i was talking about with all
my clients
yep because i know that the better
one sleeps and recovers the better
the results will be the easier it is for
me to work with them they're going to be
most likely less stressed that's right
most likely
much more open to to different ideas and
ways i'm going to get them to eventually
move
right and but again you know when you
throw the awareness on that
you need to have the awareness that you
even need to sleep in recovery
right yeah so that's why they're all
going to feed into each other
and the one above it is going to help
the one below it even more
yes so um within that obviously sleep
and recovery
and there's so much within the recovery
um aspect
and also before i finish to number three
not only do i use
quality as a distinctive um word
um there's also a low level
sort of primitive aspect and high level
high tech
aspect to all of these yeah so i like
that a lot
and i i embedded that into it because of
the very thing
i know there's lots of people out there
who think well
in order to work with josh you have to
have a lot of money you got to be famous
no you don't there's a lot of stuff that
i i mean i give out a free
podcast with free content that i pay for
yeah so it doesn't get more free than
that right you just got to listen in if
you really want to know what it's like
to work with me go listen to my podcast
or listen to interviews like this in
which we
talk about these things right um so
there's there's going to be a
sort of primitive version and there's
going to be a
very modern high-tech version and a
blend of everything in between
on each of the pillars yeah okay that's
really interesting
in a sense it kind of reminds me of the
synthesis of
indigeneity and modernity and i i love
that i couldn't say it better
you have a way with words my friend
thank you and look at this like this is
i love how you bring them for each one
of these points you're going to have
an sort of indigenous holistic old
school
primal mentality along with a modern
tech driven
mentality with quantified self
biometrics all this type of [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's going to be great and i
wouldn't have had the
wherewithal or the the um
the importance of pointing that out had
i not had the childhood that i had
exactly
you get what i mean totally so when
someone comes to me
or challenges me with like yeah but like
why you got to do all this spend all
this money this stuff is so expensive
and why are you doing it
it's like i get it i i mean this is what
i spend
investments on i invest in myself in my
career
because i have the ability to and i also
know that
it's part of who i am if i'm gonna spend
money on something i'm gonna use it
yeah right so if i want to make sure i
use it and i'll go ahead and
and you know spend the thousand dollars
sometimes that it costs to buy certain
gadgets um but best believe i'm gonna
get the most out of it
and if i can pass that on to someone and
say look save your money
here's a a more primitive indigenous way
of doing it yeah
then there you go love it now i just
helped you out as well
made me feel good and anyway pillar
number three
or maybe there's the modern examples
that are actually superior to the
indigenous practices as well
yeah that's great absolutely absolutely
absolutely and
it just goes back to being curious
enough to want to explore
all the ends of the spectrum exactly you
know the parts of the spectrum
so number three is quality
consumption
i love this consumption of both food and
water
and air and information am i hitting it
you said it without me even saying it
and and
again i love it because you are very
intuitive and you and you
get it right and i've explained this on
several podcasts but i always say that i
chose the word consumption
on purpose and with with much intention
because
it used to be when i was practicing
nutrition everyone talked about
only what they ate and like okay well so
you should eat this and eat that
but i grew up in a culture where you
drink soda and so
you know yeah you might eat healthy you
might be within your macros you might be
within whatever but if you're
if you're drinking soda and things like
that you can't forget to add that
in as well so then i started talking
about food and drinks
right and then then i found myself
saying well wait a minute
if also who you surround yourself with
and the the energy even from the lights
or lack thereof like the
junk light junk food junk energy
right because we emit energy so if
you're around a negative person all the
time
that could be just as bad as eating a
snickers bar and drinking a dr pepper
that's so well said yes so so well
consumption
had to be a ha was the only word i could
even
describe that covers all of that yeah
because what do you consume
i use input is what i use for
very good yeah input's what i used for
the seed theory chapter 2 and high level
perception that
you have to be so vigilant of the inputs
input stream of everything that comes in
and so
uh yeah that's great this is reminding
me a lot of
robert pierce's zen in the art of
motorcycle maintenance the metaphysics
of quality
because he asks what is quality that's
just a fundamental question to students
and
people you know and to try and answer
that question of what is
quality will inevitably lead you more
towards
well-being flourishing abundance
goodness prosperity
heaven enrichment all these sort of
words of higher morals higher ethics
higher spirituality
all this type of stuff that will get you
closer and closer to this archetype of
like
christ or buddha or laos or confucius or
whatever and then
and then you become more and more of a
channel for that throughout your life
and so that's why i think you honing in
on having this word
quality in front of all of these is so
interesting because it
it acts as a mechanism for other people
to think
what is quality bingo
bingo bro i need to that's why i need to
have you on my team because you you
you you're understanding what i'm
putting out there
but you just have a way of avoiding it
and that's exactly right
it's like the quality is also a spectrum
so there's a spectrum within
all of the pillars but then even the
word quality has a spectrum
right so you know it's like and again it
goes back to these layers
and if it wasn't for us having this
conversation sometimes these things
don't get fleshed out which is why i
think it's
beautiful that our friend shaker pie put
us together
because he knows that there is some
synergy there he knows that
we could probably talk for hours and
maybe we will
but um the yeah this is this is a very
very very good
good um piece in fact when you when you
said that there is the question
on what is quality right that's what the
question is there's a question that
me and most of my friends and my in my
real friend network
and i say the real friend network the
people that i consider
real friends and i spend most time
talking with and things like that
real friends yeah how many of us
have them um i asked a question and i
know shaker listening right now he's
he he knows what this question is but i
always pose the question of
what is ego yeah this is good
and that this is good is a very
very interesting not only is it
interesting
an interesting question because it's a
hard one to answer but i love to
see and feel and understand what people
consider to be the answer yes exactly
because it's it's like what is love
right you know there's many things we
can say about what is love but
what is ego is interesting and i have a
very
strong understanding of what i feel
ego is and it's embedded within these
pillars
excellent excellent okay so why don't
why don't we
let's go through the pillars and then go
to the ego is that probably the
best up to you yeah let's do that i
thought you were just about to do an ad
for a moment i'm like
why don't we take a break before we do
this yeah
so for for any for anyone that's uh
tuning in
and interested in uh you know
brand deals uh advertising uh that type
of stuff just uh
simulation series gmail.com but it has
to be ethically and morally aligned is
number one
key so yeah uh so reach out to us
and uh let's um let's let's
fund this to do all the cool things that
we want to yeah keep doing with it
uh and then yeah i think we'll do four
and five and then we'll do
the description of the ego in its
relation to yeah okay cool
so just getting cool deja vu right now
yeah i love it i love it all right deja
vu is so interesting okay
um number four yes is quality activeness
excellent okay and now
before we even get to five i'll have you
understand
that you know keep in mind
my claim to fame
or claim to infam in fame
is as a fitness trainer
so most people who
have heard of me and and they start to
understand my posing of this five
pillars the one being the most important
most people would assume that i would
talk about exercise first
yeah right i love this but the fact that
we
chose the most upstream being awareness
and then sleep and recovery and then
consumption and then activeness
it's like well wait maybe exercise
shouldn't play as big of a
role as we think it should right because
if you do all these well
you do the next one even better so
quality activeness is
the very cliche idea of just moving
as much as you can find opportunities to
move
because each of these the the higher the
number or the lower the number so
number one through four movement culture
yeah
yeah yeah the you know we should be able
to do
awareness much more than we could ever
do sleeping
in recovery right exactly we should be
able to awareness is the moment to
moment
yes basis of the highest
yeah yeah right and then from there
everything else is natural flows yeah
right yeah so like if you know sleep and
recovery we should be able to do longer
than we would do consuming yeah right
consuming
of even food drink whatever and then we
should be able to be
way more active than we are
exercising yeah okay so i could
walk all day long and be active but
never consider that to be exercise
that's right and so it goes back to
number five and the idea of well what is
quality exercise
right so is five quality exercises okay
it is okay
yeah so it's okay interesting yeah so
that that should cause people to ask a
question and i say this a lot
anytime there's a question there's an
opportunity to educate
and that education can come in
in both ways on both sides you know i i
get a chance to understand something
that someone else
what their answer would be or their
perspective is um
and then maybe i have my own perspective
but
i think quality exercise is something
that you
plan that you have a certain objective
whereas uh activeness the objective is
just to be active
that's right right so activeness is kind
of more like
me going like hmm i'm gonna take a
break from my you know my wrists and my
and my lower back i'm gonna go stand out
in the sun for a bit stretch a bit do a
little bit of yoga a couple seconds
couple maybe a couple of minutes and
then come back in
keep on the flow exercises like i'm
scheduling an hour so that i can go and
go on this bike ride go on this hike
go to this lift some weights yes
everything go around on the beach this
kind of stuff
a very easy way to kind of separate
those
is one usually requires you to
change into a different set of clothing
or shoes
oh there you go that's a good way to
that is a good way to differentiate it
yeah
i see that so we could be very active in
fact we are the fact that i'm moving my
hands and my mouth and my
i mean because you're going to sweat
usually also that's another
usually you do sweat usually yeah in
that exercise yeah yeah
usually and and you're you're changing
maybe your your
you know your different metabolics right
so maybe you go from aerobic to
anaerobic
um or your heart rate changes and
there's more consumption happening
within the body right so
um that's typically the the
differentiating factor but
um yeah it's it activeness is a is an
interesting one because
on the body to metabolize more yeah yeah
right so there's ways to to really
uncover that
but i purposefully set it up in this in
this
way to get people to go wow
so maybe i should think less about how
much i'm exercising yeah
yeah and more about the quality of my
awareness as the first first thing
so for those that are also only
listening as well we'll give you guys
the breakdown
um five pillars for optimal health and
wellness
by josh holland one quality
awareness most upstream two
quality sleep and recovery three
quality consumption four
quality activeness five quality
exercise and i love this
a lot as well because it also deeply
relates with
michael holt who we just had on the show
a couple days ago
and for him he has his
similar style pillars and what's
incredible
is that there's not only so much synergy
between
these pillars and that in a sense is
happening across the planet
for those that are very synthetic that
are grabbing from many
wellness disciplines and and creating
things like this
and so in a sense it becomes like a
perennial wellness wisdom
just like there's the perennial mystic
traditions around the
unity of all being in existence there's
also the
perennial wellness traditions and those
that are most awake
including you and michael you guys both
put your awareness amazing
at the top and that's that's the number
one thing is
that self realization and
self-actualization
so the full self-realization of
the unity of all being in existence we
like to call that the symphony
and then the full self-actualization
which is
can i be in the most efficacious
highest moral ethical pursuit of my
north star which is like my
solo in the symphony and so can you hold
both the symphonic oceanic
unity of being in existence while you
pursue
a high moral excellence
virtuous solo in bringing a unique
contributory gift
into the world and it starts with
asking yourself what is my awareness
what is my awareness pre-coloration
pre-phenomenology pre-qualia what is my
awareness
is that what we call god
is that the nature of existence
is this and is this something that we
can
drive more via like our friends leona
moon
is this something that we can drive more
into the hearts of children
for them to realize this for them to
become the better architects
of the future and so it starts with
with awareness with quality awareness
beautifully put and that basically
answers
the ego part awesome let's let's hear
from you from you on the ego part yeah i
mean
what you just pointed out is literally
what i feel to be
the ego which is quality awareness
and because everything else almost
doesn't matter
if you know you can look at ego being a
negative thing
and which it does typically have a
negative connotation
when it's just kind of thrown around in
in conversations
but there's also a positive side to it
yeah and that positive side is what
enables us to actually know
who we are who i am yeah
yeah because without it none of this
matters
because then you know we just do what we
do and there's nothing else you're just
a blob
in a spec in this unified field i mean
if you really
imagine what it's like to be
not even a a sand a piece of a sand
grain
you know it's like if you think of a
piece of sand sand grain and say that's
that's you amongst
the rest of us around the world you
start to realize that wow
it's we it is more about the unified
field
than just what am i doing today and how
am i affected
by wearing a mask or not wearing a mask
and you know and uh
my being able to see my family or not be
able to see my family or
it all comes back to the awareness and
what impacts
me impacts a lot of people it's a ripple
effect a butterfly effect like we talked
about earlier
so i always think that the quality
awareness is what
ultimately is the ego
yeah and whether you use it in a
negative sense yeah
or use it in a positive sense is the
quality aspect of it
yeah the spectrum yes yes that's i see
that i see that now
and there's
again a like kind of like a perennial
philosophy and psychology around
around human development and evolution
from the child
to the adult across all of the different
greats
like jean piaget and lawrence kohlberg
eric erickson
ken wilbur shirobindo the mother mirror
alfasa
claire graves domback chris cowan i've
done a lot
of analysis of what they've put out
and the perennial wisdom across them
in child and human and adult development
is something along the lines of that we
go from this
more egoic
state of consciousness
to a more gradually to a more
social state of consciousness to a more
ethno state of consciousness to a more
world state of consciousness than to a
transpersonal
state of consciousness then to a
non-dual state of consciousness and then
what we hypothesize is the symphonic
consciousness
which we mentioned a little bit ago
which would be
something like what you were saying
which is where the ego
is this ken wilbur calls this
transcending and including
all of the stages because you're
including you're transcending and
including the stages
and the ego becomes something that's
extremely healthy it becomes something
that
is what the self-actualization process
is which is where you play that unique
solo that unique contributory gift
but you're doing it from a state of
unity god christ buddha consciousness
from that level of being
and you see the self in the other every
person
every creature everything the sufi
mystics had
a saying it was everywhere you look you
see the face of god
and so the more that you come from that
angle
the less you have any proclivity for any
malevolence
negativity at all and so
this is i see the relationship there and
i also see the relationship as you were
saying
in you know in chapter seven we have
it's um the sorting algorithm in high
level perception and
we talk about the synthesis you have to
you have to drain the dirty bath water
you have to take the baby and so like
modernity and indigeneity both have
their
dirty bath water but they both have the
beautiful baby in each of them and we
have to synthesize them together
and in this case each one of these
pillars
has their own on the spectrum from
indigeneity to modernity they have their
own unique contributory gifts to bring
together and synthesize and to drain
that
dirty bath water so i see that embedded
in this too
it's super super rich and it makes a
bunch of sense
now and we haven't even gotten into the
biohacking stuff but it's
but now it makes a lot of sense why
people are like
you know josh holland like he's the guy
like that's
so that's it dude well thank you thank
you for putting that together like that
and it's i'm glad you even just brought
that up
the fact that we've been talking however
long we've been talking
and this is the stuff that matters right
yeah the other stuff is fluff
right like of course like you know the
biohacking stuff can be
implemented whenever or never yeah right
yeah so if it becomes this thing
that allows people to come to me to say
you know i've been really wanting to get
into biohacking what is it
and they see this guy named josh harlan
maybe they then go well let me this he's
a little bit deeper than
what i imagined and what was that so
he's talking about
how to work with erectile dysfunction
but now he's also talking about
how to sleep but now he's talking about
what to eat and then he's climbing trees
and then he's barefoot yeah yeah then
it's like ah yeah there's much more to
all this stuff
you know and at the end of the day we're
all biohackers
it's just that what's what's sexy if you
will is what can go on instagram today
right and uh this whole social dilemma
because you know you're not going to see
many people on instagram
doing a meditation that's you know
mind-blowing right because how do you
document that
right uh maybe fear and loathing in las
vegas but like
yeah it's interesting it's interesting
that you said that
because it's been an hour of
convo and what this
tells me is that
probably although it's a balance between
the indigeneity and the modernity
i do think it's probably there's some
skewedness
to the individuality side of this
because we spent that whole
bit especially like the last whatever 20
minutes unpacking
these pillars and that like
in these pillars are what is you could
say is like perennial
wisdoms around wellness and flourishing
um and start starting with that quality
awareness and then all these other
downstream things
but also what i
love about science engineering modernity
technology what i love about this
is that we get like in chapter six
in ai coach we have this
out of all of our graphics that sort of
illustrate a lot of the points that
we've been talking about
throughout this including that sort of
symphonic consciousness where you have
both the symphony and the
individual solo we have graphics for all
of these things
that i've been mentioning throughout and
this is very important to have these
visualizations
along the way what the sort of tech
modernity
hacking gives you is it gives you this
thing this is like what we call the ai
coach in chapter six
it's like if i can get a stream of my
biometrics and this is what you know
shaker and ted altrucoso and the whole
home hope
community are very passionate about as
well is that
if you can get a stream of your
biometrics
especially at the level of the
metabolomics
to identify when there are imbalances
occurring
and then heal those quickly adjust those
quickly
in order to prevent the downstream
pathology from developing
you can retain youthful homeostatic
capacity
you can feel like an 18 year old when
you're 70.
and that's where you can hit like aubrey
gray calls it the longevity escape
velocity and you can
choose if and when you want to die
rather than it just coming and hitting
and so plus all these other incredible
benefits but other things with the ai
coach besides you know biohacking for
uh the uh eradicating the pathologies
and retaining youthfulness capacity is
other things like
if i can take a readout
of my potentially
eeg and and and an ekg
sort of my the states of my of my
both neural signature and my heart rate
variability
in ways that can enrich me on a
sort of on a moment-to-moment like
feedback level where
it's like you know maybe there's sort of
some like creeping up of like an egoic
consciousness or a primal consciousness
or something that is uh maybe
serving some sort of short term ism one
marshmallow behavior of you know
smashing the bag of cheetos rather than
you know delaying and having a little
bit of salad or some apple and stuff
like that right
and maybe you can get these
interventions that come thanks to this
these ai coaches and what's called
homomorphic encryption which is what
allows
all of your massive data visualization
to have
the best possible artificial general
intelligence computational capacities
give you insight without ever decrypting
your data
so now you also have math and crypto
that allows you cryptography that allows
you to have
uh an encrypted data have these
beautiful insights
happen without the decryption ever
occurring so you have all of these
sort of you know biohacking towards my
north star
though all these patterns that we can
leverage
in order to to benefit us i'm curious
like there's
there's a bunch of these that that you
have i mean
so you have us let's see if i can get
this right there's a certification
in cpt in cms
or and then ems electrical muscle
stimulation
primal blueprint coach movenat l1
movement movement l1
okay so tell us about yeah tell us about
yeah tell us about these because i don't
i don't know these
um and this is kind of really related to
what we're talking about and also
not only tell us about them but also
tell us about the
certification processes in them and also
the
which biohacking technologies go with
each of them and we can do some demos
and stuff along the way yeah cool
cool so um yeah
with with my background in trying to be
as
well-rounded as possible i wanted to
search out for
different certifications that would
would enable me to step into
certain platforms step onto certain
platforms or
step into certain doors and so one of
the first ones
is the nasm in asm cpt
which is the national academy of sports
medicine
certified personal trainer oh cool yeah
national
academy of sports medicine certified
personal trainer
nasm cpt now some cpt yeah got it
um and that's a very sort of um
it's more classic classical training
absolutely that's like what you get when
you get the fitness coaches at the gyms
is that exactly right okay
and it's probably the most uh well-known
and well recognized
accepted certification out there so
there's
it's usually down to two major ones
especially in this country
nasm and ace academy
of uh i think corrective exercise
um something along that line don't don't
quote me on that but
um nasm and ace and
i've gone through certifications with
both
via different platforms the thing that
i never really liked
about the world of fitness
is that you had to have this it's almost
like driving a car
getting a driver's license when you get
a driver's license it doesn't mean
you're a good driver
it just means that you've taken a test
to prove to some person
one person that you're you're able to
drive right
but it's not until you get on the road
you that you find out like wait a minute
i'm not such a good driver
or maybe you are the best driver but
then even that's a spectrum because
are you trying to be a race car driver
which is a different certificate man
this applies to
like the mcat and doctors this supplies
to law
all of it um all every field that
kind of requires one of these yes
certifications like it kind of baselines
you in
yeah but then how well studied are you
across the field
okay i look at it as like hey you got a
certification cool
so it you've proven that you can retain
enough information
for long enough time to be able to
answer a few questions
that they set for you okay because
i can't tell you the last time i used
the opt model
of you know what it means to to set up a
client
with you know okay this is for these six
weeks you do this
for these six weeks you do that but then
every time i would
train a client it was like they didn't
want to hear all that
you know and sometimes like when uh like
let's say
when i first got certified and i'm like
okay i'm good to go
got my certificate up i'm gonna start
hitting up all the major clients
and this was basically right
when i was sort of parting ways with
madonna working with madonna for the
first time
because i wanted to to set out and start
my own gym and my own studios and have
you know just start to do more within
the the fitness and health world
so i started to get the the top of the
tops of the certifications and nasm was
one of them
but every time i would train a new
client and this would be people who are
some of the wealthiest people in the
world at a
fitness it's not even a fitness but it's
a a club a membership
exclusive club in new york city called
the core club
when i would train different clients
there i would realize that like
maybe i would set up three different
exercises this many reps this much time
and this and that but then
they would come up the stairs and they
might be in a boot
because they had a skiing accident but
they're going to come and get their
workout
so i'm like oh well on the program i had
you doing box jumps
and lunges and squats but you can't do
any of that so i would have to scratch
that
and come up on the fly with some things
that i might have learned from this and
that right
and there's no amount of certifications
that's going to prepare you for that
yeah yeah so again back to my curiosity
i'm like well
okay i'll get this to kind of get the
base and
let everyone else know that okay this
guy is not just some quack
coming off the street saying that he can
train people okay i do have a base
in a sense that's adding the art to the
science right i love that
right right exactly so so nasm was one
of the main ones that i kind of keep in
fact it's coming up on um
renewal and you have to do just like in
the medical field you have to do
uh um what is it called ceus which would
be continuing
education units yeah and it's the same
in in most healthy wellness fields right
and so you have to do a number of those
just so that they know that you're not
just like
getting the certification and then never
coming back to it
so yep anyway so that's that the cms
is certified micronutrient specialist
certified micronutrient specialist
interesting interesting so yeah break
this down for us yeah
that's essentially it's just again it's
a number it's i was i'm a good
test taker i guess i take tests well
right so i can retain information i have
a
photographic memory and i'm able to
visualize certain things and i can
you know do it but ultimately what that
was is it showed that i was proficient
in being able to identify and understand
the differences between
vitamins and minerals and um you know
macronutrients micronutrients and which
ones are synergistic and which ones are
antagonists and how to help a person
through
iron deficiencies and well like all of
these things
but that's also a part of one of my
first health coaching certifications
and this was through um the cms that i
have here
was through the jason and mira calton
of calton nutrition and uh they they had
some great books
uh one was called um naked
naked health i think it was called and
then another one
is um rich food poor food and so
yeah i have to reach that poor dad yeah
that's great yeah yeah
it's really cool they really dive into
like basically
um husband and wife i think it was you
know the doctor dr
jason calton um had a patient
in mira calton and i don't want to
butcher the story but essentially
they worked with each other he helped
her through her issues
with the protocols that are being talked
about to this day
and so they they kind of he healed her
of her issues
she wasn't able to have a baby they
ultimately got married she became
fertile they have
kids but they traveled across all the
continents
to to study and live with all the
different communities and figured out
okay here's what's messing us up as a
people
and here's what's helping us and what i
love is that they
have protocols for any type of
eating profile if you will so if you're
a vegan okay here's the best way to
become
nutrient sufficient because they've
discovered that
the most drastic thing to our society
is nutrient deficiencies interesting
and then can you give us just a couple
quick um bits on the nutrient
deficiencies like what's the number one
or number two like nutrient deficiencies
and this would be like united states in
the world because remember
in the world oh we're saying worldwide
what's the worldwide one
well uh vitamin d deficiency interesting
yeah
it's typically like the the that and
magnesium
would probably be the the two main
deficiencies
that and where are we supposed to be
getting most of our
vitamin d and magnesium from from the
sun
both yeah well the the sun is going to
give you
the the bulk of your vitamin d but again
it depends on how well again it's on
expect a spectrum right are you wearing
clothing when you're out
yeah exactly um do you have enough um
fat sustenance are you eating enough
because vitamin d is a fat soluble
vitamin right so you need a
fatty environment to be able to absorb
it properly so interesting
there's so many layers there's so many
magnesium also from sun
well no so magnesium we would get from
ideally we would get from quality water
spring water water
but has been a has been enhanced and
affected by the sun
so okay right so it goes back to again
are we
are we actually drinking spring water or
are we drinking tap water that's been
filtered that have no nutrients
or far less nutrients sure sure right so
there's okay i see
so that's it so then so then so
so c m s certified
micro nutrient micro nutrient specialist
specialist
will dive you into the on the nutrition
side quite deeply
um on and this is normally when it's
client-facing is something around
um do you go as deep as like the
phlebotomy to do the blood work and then
you
then provide insight for uh
and nutrients is that what it's like yes
and
um i have to always preface that i am
not a doctor and i
am not a phlebotomist nor am i a
physical therapist um
i have extensive background in a lot of
these modalities and experience
um but i that enables me because of the
profile that i've created and because of
the
you know the the networks i work within
i'm able to
outsource that quite easily yeah so most
of the time i can call on
anyone you can imagine in any kind of
field especially if it
involves some sort of health or wellness
journey yeah
you know from neurologists to to
you know lab technicians anything you
can think of
yeah um so okay that all kind of stemmed
from my first
foray into the world of health coaching
was the cms certification and then the
primal blueprint health coach that's
that's also another health coaching
certification which was a bit more
holistic and more extensive and it was
way beyond just the
micronutrient and nutrient deficiencies
insufficiency
um it was more holistic so like that
would have been a section of
so the primal blueprint health coach
certification was very extensive
yeah very extensive okay cool so it was
one of my
one of my favorite ones right in the
health coaching
sense and then you touched on the other
thing that's been listed is ems uh ems
certified
and ems is electrical muscle stimulation
and i brought a couple tools
uh with me for you to try if you if you
still want but
the um electrical muscle stimulation i
have
various certifications across different
platforms and different
brands but you know ems
as a whole has been around for a long
time it's been
such a long time and my custom
my company system fit with the emphasis
on the stem
stim is because of the stimulation
right the electrical muscle stimulation
but also
we we sort of have a i say we
my my my group my company we came up
with the idea of stimulus being a part
of it as well because it's not just
electrical muscle stimulation that we
work with as a company
we're sort of a biohacking company that
that
implores all the pillars we just went
through yeah and so
if part of that can be sort of can help
a person through their journey
and if the ems is part of it great if
vasper cold thermogenesis with blood
flow restriction is a part of it we have
another show we did
we did a demo on bass for on the show
yeah
yeah yeah they're they're great guys um
there's a big part of my studio i mean
it's one of the things i missed i love
it yeah um
but it's what caused me to wear i almost
brought today
ice packs because i wear ice packs now
on my body and i almost brought those
today for you to
to try it i just didn't have enough time
getting out of the house and
i probably would be speaking with a
chatter while we're talking and that's
probably not because it's being colder
yeah yeah yeah but anyway okay um okay
so ems can involve
anything from stem which
uh e-stem is what most people know of
know of in the uh the physical therapy
world where you may have had like a tens
therapy unit
um t-e-n-s and those
usually affect the nerve the nerves
throughout the body
as opposed to the muscles and so
electrical muscle stimulation
is ems and it's designed to
contract and affect excite the muscles
right they both have a sort of a similar
effect because ems
can affect the nerves and tens therapy
can affect the muscles
but one is designed for blocking nerve
pain
or blocking pain via the nerve and
that's the tens therapy so you may have
seen that
um if you've had to go to the physical
therapist for a back problem or
whatever and they put these little
electrodes on you and it's a very low
level
stimulation whereas what what i do
and the various different suits and
and devices i've worked with is we have
a suit that connects to each of the
major muscle groups throughout your body
so this here would be the the abs the
obliques
we got the glutes low back
hamstrings quads inner thighs
i think i may have said chest already
but there's the chest the biceps triceps
the traps middle back i think i covered
them all yeah
wow wow so then the
the bodysuit goes on and then there's
an electrical stimulation that happens
through all of those patches at those
core muscles
yeah so for instance there's a
there's a little battery pack that looks
like an old school pager do you remember
pagers for sure yeah
yeah yeah so this is like an old-school
page or a little thicker than one of
those motorola pagers
um and so this connects to
magnetically and this is gold oh
interesting
oh wow so this is completely wireless
yeah
so you guys are so dope yeah so we're
just charging a battery pack
and then we're taking we're taking this
with us wherever we go
and you're literally on the beach
walking and you're
getting the electro magnetic
or like electro muscle electrical muscle
muscle
stimulation while you're doing your
anything that you're up to yeah yeah so
this is how a person would be
and then we now have it refined to where
you can use your iphone or
tablet um and you can adjust
the strength of the electrical current
and
yeah so maybe you can turn on or off
certain patches down the line absolutely
like that yeah yeah yeah and then um
you know and again this is morphed from
my experience i was one of the first
american
certified ems trainers and
i mean there's been a hint there's a
handful but
i've worked now with i think six
different brands six different companies
and six different
types of devices and tools and we've got
it down to
to where now finally my company has been
working with a manufacturer
to create our own suit yeah so this is
you know my company's suit um this is
why you see the company's logo
here on the left chest and
so that's there
boom so cool that that brain
logo is designed to depict synaptic
firing
and that's kind of it's hard to depict
movement within a static image but
um that's what that is designed to
depend okay
and so that's stimulus and stimulation
right
and this so the brand is stim and fit
stim fit system fit oh stim fit
system fit system fit yeah okay
s y s
t i m mm-hmm ah system
yes and then f-i-t right but it's with a
space
no it's all together all together system
oh cool
okay yeah cool cool so we we obviously
like with
i don't know if it's obvious but maybe
by now people listening to this show
you understand that everything i do and
i put my hands on has
great intention and also it's purposeful
and i like to use
a lot of play on words and so there is a
system to this
system to all of this right so what is
the point well
okay the the point could be to
activate parts of the body that don't
get activated as much um
to maybe save time so you could you
could get
a lot of bang for your buck with a
workout like this because instead of
working out for an hour you can work out
for 20 minutes and and feel like you've
worked out for three days
exactly fast protect
and so with this you can also because
you can use it as a physical therapy
tool
so let's say that certain muscles in
your body have atrophied
well you could use this to to turn it
back on so to speak
to get it to build back up you could use
it to lose weight you can use it to
improve your endurance you can use it to
do a number of things
improve your strength to get muscle size
you can do it to lose weight
so depending on how you use it
if you work out with it essentially the
goal is to enhance the workout
so the tagline we use with my company
systemfit
is effective efficient and quantifiable
yeah so those three things and i and you
probably understand that i chose
effective first
for a reason because who cares if it's
efficient if it's not effective
right so it needs to be effective first
and then it needs to be efficient and
that's why
what you're looking at is our latest
iteration of this
of this suit because it started out
where my company and myself i had to
work with
huge devices that were on a stand and
there's probably something on my
instagram somewhere
um if you go like years back um way down
the line but there's probably something
on there that
shows um me connected to
a device that's in front of me and it's
connected by cables even down yeah
and that's what we had to do for a long
period of time like
i remember going on with on tour having
to have like
separate luggage just for these devices
and
yeah we're getting closer to it now um
but now
today we have a suit that you literally
just throw in the wash
let it hang dry if you as long as you
have your iphone and this little battery
pack is charged
you got yeah there are some so this one
down keep going a little bit lower
that one on the the left there that's
me just finishing up a session and
oh yeah see there's the there's the
machine in the corner
and i'm having to connect myself to this
machine and a suit with all those cables
i can only be in in that area yeah right
that's nowhere near as efficient no
right and you know i'm
i'm doing a lot of things with it right
that's me performing the x3 bar workout
which i love the x3 bar
but that was one of the early units it's
one of the first
fda approved ems units but you could
train one person
at one time in one space and that was it
now fast forward to what we can do now
it's like i can train
multiple people with one
device with one ipad or a person can
take their own phone connect to the app
and do their own workout so this is
designed to be what you have in your
hands is designed to be
a consumer unit a unit that's not too
sophisticated
because you have to be certified with
these what we've been doing before
for many years is we had to certify all
of our trainers to be
ems certified to understand how to
train a person not to kill a person
right
um yeah to where now we have this
suit and an apparatus for a person can
do at home you could do it
yeah anybody can do it yeah and and
that's what i think is really really
cool so we've
we've really entered into new territory
and
several years ago i knew once i first
tried this i
knew that it was going to change the way
we work out
and uh and it's still new in the u.s but
it's huge in europe
so yeah it's huge it's like as many
ems studios as there are probably
starbucks
yeah yeah
what damn that's crazy that many
yeah that's a lot so people are good
what they're just walking in for you
know 20 minutes of just
ems and they're you know walking out
hopefully feeling
a lot healthier a lot better yeah yeah
and like
that video you just saw with that
machine yeah that was a 20 000
machine yeah it's being democratized and
it requires
entrepreneurs like you to take the risk
like this in order to democratize it
yeah bingo
so that was a 20 000 device that was
clunky
you know it's hard to get around with
you have to check it or you know you
have to
carry it on and hope that when it
arrives that it doesn't get damaged
which has happened to me
several times on a tour to now you go to
something like this
that's around three thousand dollars and
is the same effect in fact this one's
even better
because this uses dc current as opposed
to ac current yeah okay
and now you can use your phone
put in your bag and no one would even
know it doesn't require
its own whole bag yeah yeah right you
can wash it you can go
so it allows for much better compliance
yeah and and it's a fraction of the cost
but to your point
super interesting my company had to buy
in order to get a good rate
a decent rate we had to buy 10 of the 20
000
units so just imagine what that's like
yeah exactly and then we were
in a studio in midtown where we had to
spend 45 grand a month just to keep the
lights on
yeah yeah yeah so you know now pandemic
happens and here we are
yeah i'm chilling man we got you know
yeah
so yeah it's a important
story for entrepreneurs because you t
you take on the big risk to try and
democratize
something that's healing and wellness
driven for the world and
eventually gets down to this this level
and this is the three thousand dollar
level which is fantastic and
eventually you'll get down you know even
more and
you'll be able to get these for
hopefully the same price as a drone
you know and like that's really awesome
um
and hopefully uh stuff like this becomes
more
like you said mainstream in the us
because uh i have yet to
undergo like uh
besides in my imagination uh a world
where
we have on every street corner instead
of the
egregious amounts of junk food um where
we have
uh healthy uh quality of
food and wellness and awareness and all
of these different
aspects that would be great if it was
that in mass like we could just walk
down the street and just jump between
wellness yeah uh oriented
this is awesome so this is available
right now still
it um yes and no okay if you
if you are lucky enough to to know me
and hang out with me
then you know all of my friends have
been tasked to be guinea pigs and so
before going into full launch full
production
i have to make sure that everything is
perfect on it yeah yeah so
you know this is our fourth iteration
and you know it's like each time i feel
like i'm so close to
pulling the trigger on going into full
production mode but
thank god something told me to hold off
because you keep iterating to make it
better
yeah because like we used to have um a
zipper on the back
i think i have one in here at the bottom
that one's only the front
and now it's in the front because the
zipper on the back is cool but it's hard
to get on yourself and take off yourself
in the front it's better yeah and it
goes
that goes to say like look i was able to
get it up
up and down easy but there are people
that are not flexible
right right and so just because i can do
it
yeah user experience testing yeah it
doesn't matter so
yeah i had a handful of people it was i
think three different people told me
yeah it's a little difficult
i'm like okay back to the drawing board
exactly yeah that's it yeah
it's i liked the fact that it was on the
front very thank you yeah
thank you yeah so you know it's like it
doesn't wait it doesn't weigh that much
even though if you scroll down you could
probably see
well there's one on the right of me
doing several workouts with it
so i'm just teasing it right now so well
no no like you passed
there's one in the middle there yeah
that's me at my apartment doing some
crazy work with it
and um if the logo is in the front that
means the zipper's in the back
if the logo is logo's in the middle on
the front so that's one of the suits in
which
the zipper is still in the back i love
this workout i do similar stuff like
this
yeah very edo portal style yeah i do
this other stuff i love it
so that is just so you know movement
culture
that is basically indigenous
meats modern i would agree yeah that's a
good way to put it
because that's me doing some of the man
you're wearing exactly
exactly that's cool if you don't know
you don't know right but if you do know
you know
and so to give you an example
on the rest of some of those other
certifications um
is some of my most fun
and exciting certifications which is
move nat which is what we talked about
um earlier as well movenat is
one of those certifications that caused
me to go
okay i feel at home i feel very
one with nature i feel like this is what
it's like to actually
like what is the importance of of why we
do what we do
yeah you know and i talk about this on
on some other podcast but like
it doesn't quite matter if you look like
a
a chiseled god if you can't protect your
family
yeah right when [ __ ] hits the fan
and you know something comes up and
you've got
to you know you got three guys outside
ready to like take your food
or water because they don't have food or
water
can you protect your family and so does
that mean you have to learn jujitsu
maybe if you're curious like me you will
or if you're fortunate enough to grow up
in a sense in a martial arts world where
you
you know what or better yet maybe you
need to learn how to use weapons
whether you believe in the idea of of of
gun control or not
it might be important to know how to
defend yourself
if something came at you right so this
is
what the idea of like movement and being
a human is all about
is being able to to survive and then
ultimately thrive
right but you got to survive first yeah
right so it's it's it's interesting so i
say all that to say
i relearned how to climb a tree by
practicing move not yeah i re-learned
that the world is your gym right to be
able to
satisfy the idea of balance can you go
and walk on a rail
and and if you can can you balance on a
rail first of all yeah just choose any
rail
right can you walk on a rail or first
can you balance on it yeah second can
you walk on it
exactly well what's the importance of
that maybe that's the only path to get
you
away from danger maybe yeah and maybe
it's gonna
strengthen your core and body to a point
to where you'll
you won't uh accidentally incur some
sort of downstream
injury so there's many different it's
part of that whole
oh oh quality
uh activeness yeah yeah and and again
good point because in that very one
exercise let's just call it
walking on a rail in that one exercise
it could be quality activeness and it
can be quality exercise and
yeah and quality and quality awareness
of course of course because that's
included
because that's in all of them when
you're yeah when your mind's wandering
you can't
balance on on any on anything of course
right
and so how does it fall into quality
activeness
well we could go right now without
having to change our clothes
and go balance on a rail and walk on a
rail or we could go
you know what today we're going to walk
on that really high rail
so we need to change our clothes to have
like you know is to protect us if we do
fall
yeah yeah yeah right so it's just like
one or the other or
you know we're probably going to sweat
cause it's hot outside so let's put on
like a tank top and
let's get the the the barefoot shoes you
know this is
why i like to separate and how i
separate the
activeness and exercise but anyway this
is that
was that movement movement okay and
which one
that was the so uh movement was is the
other
the last one that is oh movement is the
one where you're
using crawling yeah and climbing and
move that is like
cultural yeah yeah movement culture
movement
is kind of like take the the
biology of where you come from with uh
like lizards and it's yeah
the way i explain it is it's very
similar to
uh animal flow overflow very similar to
um primal play and very similar to edo
portals
movement culture but the thing i like
most about
movenat is there's a an extreme
amount of awareness within the
practicality of every move
yeah there's a practicality they teach
why it's practical yeah you know okay
and so that's really cool like
you know like for instance i'll give you
one example when you do a crab walk
we all kind of know what crab walk is
and we probably had to do that in pe
when we were in school right
so you're on your your your supine so
you're kind of on your back
on your feet though and your hands and
you're looking up at the ceiling or the
sky
and you move you know in a crab walk
like fashion
well and move now they teach that as
well but
the idea of doing that a good example of
of
of utilizing that is going down a hill
so if you're going downhill and you have
goods that you need to protect
to get to your family yeah you put the
goods in your lap
and then you you descale or you scale
down slowly because if you're to walk
down
you might slip you might not have enough
traction that's right yeah so you know
so there's a practical
component to it i see and then you're
listing the practical components for
people to know
as as they do the moves i like that move
naturally i like the
the animal flow i like that that that
that's a strong ways primal play
those are very strong ways to say it um
awesome i mean i totally see
the the synthesis of those and it's
application within your personalization
and your one-on-one
and virtual trainings and all this type
of stuff that's happening
um let's hit
let's hit on so simply walk the talk
you've been mentioning a little bit
about how um
the podcasts that you've been recording
have been
basically a lot of the cutting-edge
knowledge that you know you're giving
away for free via the podcast the links
in the bio below for
for everyone to check out um and
that there's like a hundred and like
thirty plus episodes there's a lot of
good content i forget how many now but
yeah
yeah yeah and so there's basically
unpacking
the wealth of knowledge that you have
disseminating that
um having guests as well on the show
um yeah the the the idea
of creating it what the the reason why
right if i ask myself why or if someone
asked me why
i wanted to finally put something out
that could be
considered a resource because
quite frankly i found myself being asked
almost the same questions
but i never like to give a padded
response i
i never like to give a cookie-cutter
response or the same response
to situations because every person is
different and i think as you get to know
me
you know that i treat each person as a
special person because we all are
right and so i know that there's a lot
of care
that goes into my response with that
person and um
you know there's that quote about um
you know you may not remember a a person
but you may
you'll always remember how they made you
feel something along those lines
and that's kind of what i live by you
know it's like
okay if i can put this
all together in a podcast and then now
when somebody asks me about
let's say photobiomodulation i can go oh
hey here's three
episodes that i did a podcast on that
might give you some answers
then they can hear this back and forth
discussion and they can go ah i was
thinking the same thing okay i get it
now
or at least if they don't they can come
back and go you know what
i didn't quite get the answer now i can
go okay but at least they tried at least
they
because are you asking me a question
just to to feel
the empty space the void in the room or
do you really want to know
about x y and z because if you really
just want
me to suggest a tool of course i can
because you know i've got
yeah i've got all these tools that i
work with right you want to actually
learn how to
fish listen to the actual episodes of me
unpacking it yeah
exactly yeah spot on likewise i say
that that that's going to be a new thing
that i end up saying on the program more
is literally like go and listen to
all the different people in the
blockchain space or the crypto space or
the emotional intelligence spirituality
space that we've had on the program if
you actually
care about learning that that specific
field i know we wanted to talk about
nunchi we should definitely talk about
nunchi
um subtle art and ability to listen
engage
others moods aka
the emotional intelligence
is a good way to say it's also called
like i
force or power which is super
interesting and and we could even call
it awareness
right yeah so there's a social awareness
there's
the um the situational awareness
right but um
nunchi is so i i have to give a shout
out to my boy
celine najar saleem
found out about this book from uh one of
his
i forget it's one of his uh teachers
um it's either either a teacher or
a a priest one of his priests friends i
think um
and he he suggested it to to salim
and then saleem as he got to kind of
know me
he started being like man there's all
these situations in which
like you used good nunchi or you used
quick nunchi and i'm like
what is what is this nunchi and he's
like i got a book for you bro yeah
so the the power of nunchi
is the name of a book by yuni hong
and um i've reached out to her i want to
try to get her on my show
um maybe you have more of a influence to
get her onto your show but
um i i find the story to be very
fascinating because the idea is is that
in korea they use nunchi as a
sort of a measure for a person's ability
to have eq right interesting so what it
would it be like
there's like a sort of a a scale of
nunchi ability and it's kind of like
based on
how much of an emotional intelligence
jedi someone is
absolutely okay yeah and so when you
when you're
good you have what's called quick nunchi
yeah
and then they they call it like like if
you're like a nunchi ninja
yeah then you will like
figure it out you a jedi mind trick the
situation right
and ultimately there's a lot of examples
in the book i would suggest anyone
listening right now to go and check out
the book it's amazing
um i listed every once in a while when
i'm reading a book because i love to
read
i will take excerpts and put it into my
instagram stories
yeah and um i love
using the goodreads app because it kind
of allows me to track
and keep a library a bookshelf of my
books but i also
use the read wise app are you familiar
with read wise not yet no
read wise is a really good app that um
has as
a part of its foundation um spaced
repetition
yeah good right yeah so it creates kind
of like flash cards
which again i'm all about learning and
cognition and memory and things like
that so
i use that and i basically take so this
is a benefit to reading books
on ibooks on
of some sort because then you can take
all of your notes all the highlighted
notes
input it into read-wise and then it
spits out
every once in a while like if you check
it every day then you know you're
getting thrown different excerpts that
you highlighted because a lot of times
let's face it we read a book
and we put it down yeah and then you
know you may catch some things like i
remember this book that kind of talked
about this or you can
take a space repetition approach and
always keep it within you
yeah you know for from time to time but
back to nunci
uh an example of nunchi
they draw so many but i'll give an
example um
let's say you walk into someone's home
and you've been invited
for dinner or whatever for whatever
reason
and you walk in and you just walk
straight to
the couch or straight to the kitchen or
whatever
but you maybe noticed that there was a
bunch of shoes piled up on the side
but you just didn't notice it enough to
like
either ask or just immediately start
taking off your shoes yeah right
in the korean culture that would be very
frowned upon yeah
totally and so the
good news would be to ask oh would you
like me to take off my shoes yeah
well in in the idea of nunchi and quick
nunchi
you wouldn't put the person you wouldn't
put someone else in the
in the situation to even say yes or no
exactly
right so someone with quick nunchi as
soon as they come in
yeah you just take off your shoes that's
it right so
that is a very low level basic
idea of what this book is about and so
some people are born with it
some people learn it yeah and many
others can
improve upon their nunchi um but i think
at least having because for instance
when i when i'm with people
one of my biggest pet peeves and i i use
pet peeves as a part of my the ending of
my
show of my my podcast yeah i i always
ask
people what are your top two pet peeves
because i feel like
pet peeves is a really good way to
understand someone beyond
the the a certain level does that make
sense
you know if we're talking about what i
do and then and then yeah and then we go
on yeah yeah
okay whatever it's great but pet peeve
is like oh that's what makes you tick
okay but why is that important to me
because that allows me
to be able to make sure you feel the
best
all the time because it's going to help
me feel good and then i'm going to want
to continue hanging out with you
so one of my pet peeves is loud chewing
smacking sure like
it it literally drives me up a wall
so much so that i can barely even
concentrate on what's at hand
yeah sure right and i've had several
situations with friends
really close friends back in new york
that i've
i i was so uncomfortable that i actually
said something
and can you imagine what that goes down
we can we can
we can do it in playful and gentle and
kind ways
like and and also the more that we kind
of bring
nunchi into the hearts of kids ninja
level nunchi to the hearts of kids
uh the more that we'll just have like a
more emotionally and spiritually
intelligent culture in general
one of the things that comes to mind a
lot to me is that
you have what you can call like the
the combinatorics of two
psyches interacting if you only go under
one or two or ten of these
combinatorics these different
combinations of
of soul personalities that you interact
with you're going to be limited
if you only hang out with scientists or
if you only hang out with artists or if
you
if you only hang out with people from
like sioux falls south dakota which is
where i'm from
okay for you it's chandler oklahoma
right
like you're you're gonna get only a
certain soul personality that you're
gonna know how to engage with and
interact with but if you start having
like
friends from korea and friends from
brazil and friends from germany
and friends from all these different
places around the world and then
all of a sudden you have to pick up on
their sole personalities in terms of
their cultures and their
their idiosyncrasies and things
and then basically you become like
joseph in the code of many colors you
become a cultural ninja
yeah uh nunchi ninja and then you just
basically glide around with high level
emotional and spiritual intelligence
with every single human that you
interact with
every culture you interact with and to
me this is like a common sense thing
that we
must bring into the hearts of young
children and so
but i but your examples are on point
like i know i know a lot of
um i know a lot of
instances like this that are sort of
like
like yeah homies that
have um potentially some of the finances
to be able to help
other homies out with what they're doing
um should help them out like whether it
be um through
uh helping cover the cost of the meal or
them going out or them
going on their travels or whatever it is
like this happens like the teacher
and the student but then the student is
a teacher for another student below them
and like that's kind of also how like
the whole uplifting
vehicle works so there's all these types
of situations like this
i'm glad and we'll probably unpack um
nunchi more with you with saleem with
yeah we're going to talk about this
concept more because i'm glad that
there's a word
besides like emotional intelligence for
it and i like how we can add the second
word ninja nunchi ninja
yeah to it as well i my friends and i
uh shaker saleem a few of us we we
talk about this right and to your point
i i think
we should all get to a point where we
can
get slightly uncomfortable with each
other that's right because
you know here's the thing when i when i
bring up
hey uh you're really chewing your food
loud
it's almost like you would think i
attacked their family
i choked them i slapped them in the face
and it's like no no no no
i just i don't know if you noticed that
like
you your food is about to fall out of
your mouth but like and then it becomes
this weird awkward thing where
maybe it could be like huh yeah
i'll just give you this really great
moment i was at uh
a summit uh last year it was super
important that this happened
and uh someone walked up to me and was
like watching
me speak in a group of other people and
she asked me you know how how do you
take like feedback about improving
yourself and i was like i [ __ ] love
feedback
about improving myself i'm like give it
to me raw and so she goes
um she goes you you have a little bit of
like gingivitis developing and she's
like you need to make sure that you're
taking better care of your teeth
and i was like wow thank you very much
for that feedback i'm like that's
that's perfect because to me i have
high enough of a level of receptive
nunchi
to where i don't even give it i don't
even give a [ __ ] how your noon
how your noon she comes to me if it
comes in a non-emotionally intelligent
way of course that's going to sting a
little bit more
um but if it comes in a highly
emotionally intelligent nunchuninji way
to me
then it's going to be easier for me to
take but she came at it from a very kind
of raw center point
and it was very easy for me to just take
in and be like dope that's really good
feedback i need to take better care of
my teeth that's
so beautiful yeah so stuff like that is
we we need to learn how to be able to
handle that and do that more because
people are really
trying to help one another in scenarios
like that
thank you to her and to you in that
situation yeah because
that's what it's ultimately all about
right and so
like like you said earlier we could take
certain situations and kind of be funny
and cute about it
but sometimes you gotta smack somebody
upside the head with it
because then otherwise if because like
for instance
it's a sledgehammer trigger versus just
a little feather which doesn't make you
do anything
because otherwise what'll happen and
this happened to a friend of mine
and you know if he's listening he's
probably laughing right now but like
it's the only time i would start to hang
out with him was after he's already
eaten
there you go i literally was like stuff
like that hey dude um he said you want
to go
eat lunch or whatever no no no no i'll
i'll meet with you
after yeah and so it's like okay can you
chill out with that because it's like i
can't even hear anything you're saying
right and so
yeah i think there is a disability so we
were talking about creating a buzzer
my friends and i oh yeah a buzzer of
like of nunchi
yeah right so like when someone's not
being nunchi
you hit the buzzer that's that's a great
that's great yeah that's uh that's one
of the ai coach things too that we could
talk about is like that buzzer
actually in that example that i was
illustrating i would say that that was
probably more of
feathers so she came to me with a
feather
about my gingivitis and i was
emotionally intelligent enough to be
receptive to where i took the feather
and i augmented my perception and my
bodily health
from the feather rather than the
sledgehammer would be me
literally being in such a bad oral
microbiome
state um oral health state that i would
literally have to
go in to uh get it taken care of uh
at a like at a dentistry level so it's
good to
listen to the feather as the awakening
trigger rather than the sledgehammer
um two last questions okay
first last question we're running long
huh yeah yeah
yeah well we have around twos and plenty
more absolutely um yeah
plenty more to do um
what do you think is the point of
reality
what do i think the point of reality is
yeah why does reality exist
that's a really good question um i i
think it goes back to what we talked
about with
the ego and awareness and um
i i haven't put much thought to to this
question
so it's a it's a it's a beautiful one i
think
that like the ego
it allows us to sort of identify who we
are
and i think it also allows us to
understand that there's
there's multiple sides to it right
because we we are good we
human society we are good at separating
ourselves from nature
but we are very much a part of nature
but we need to be in this sense of
reality to understand that we can even
affect it
so it's like we could we could say
awareness we could say ego we could say
self-actualization we could say all
these things but
i think the reality component allows us
to say okay i'm in it
but i can also take myself away from it
to look at it from a different
perspective and i think
everything is about perspective yeah so
i think i think reality
allows for perspectives
yep yep i like that yeah
yeah realities allow
what would be the
one infinite consciousness that's
undergoing the exploration that is
happening
with these realities to undergo this
diversity in oneness phenomenon where
you can have
on our earth something like eight
billion
different perspectives on the
what's going on here and so then
it's uh it's a really sort of uh if the
i think the more you baseline yourself
to more
enlightened states what you do is in the
most sort of
simple way is that you take on the
perspective of just one other person
right so that's empathy you would try
and see it from two perspectives here
and when you get to like really
enlightened states you're basically
trying to hold
all eight billion perspectives at the
same time and beyond
and that's when
that's when you become a light architect
that's when you really begin
channeling what is the next generation
more beautiful
abundant future that our hearts know is
possible
i like that i like that and then um the
last the last question
what is your favorite food
what is my favorite food um
food food i just i love
food bro yeah um i mean if i had to pick
one
i don't know i i'd have to separate that
into like
you know healthy food or not healthy
food um
right now i go to irwin a lot this is
not a plug for erwan but
i go there a lot because we're here in
la and i love it
and uh they have this very very amazing
uh gluten-free enchilada chicken
enchilada
dish i love it i love it yeah and it's
like
i get that with the buffalo cauliflower
we we've had that answer on the episode
the arrow on buffalo cauliflower
we've had that exact answer on the
episode before it's too good it's super
interesting but the chicken enchilada
gluten free there
yeah i could i could design a plate a
very large plate
but like the chicken enchiladas the
buffalo cauliflower
the gluten-free mac and cheese to die
for um
and then i have to throw some greens in
there yeah um
so i would say they have this um it's
called the
the seasonal greens all of it man it's
just yeah
it's it's the spot wow
sounds delicious i know era wants
crushing it
and um that's a cool selection of foods
of
foods that you dig um
well this has been a really powerful
conversation i've super enjoyed it i
agree
wow yeah like dude i i say this and i'm
sure people say this a lot
but i literally feel like we could go
for hours
yes yes this is this is too good yes
this has been a blast unpacking your
journey
unpacking the essence of curiosity
awareness
nunchi maximizing health and well-being
from a very synthetic perspective i love
that yeah it's no wonder that
you're succeeding at the levels you are
you found good patterns
you found the top patterns i love it
yeah thank you
good job my brother thank you appreciate
it love you tons josh
love you too bro thank you so much for
coming on the program
i love it thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know what you're
thinking
do check out the links in the bio below
we have joshua j holland.com his website
you can find
all the great info there you can also
find his instagram
in the bio below go and give him a
follow he's got great posts and great
stories a lot more information there for
you
as well as the simply walk the talk
podcast link go and subscribe
check it out check out all the great
content that he's disseminating for free
to you guys check that out
like the video share the video with
other people
that you think need to hear about this
subject and this these wisdom
subscribe if you haven't yet and also
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders the scientists the
engineers in your communities around the
world that you believe in you can
support us simulation our
links are in the bio below to support us
and help us flourish here in la achieve
our goals
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much
take good care of your health
identify those patterns we love you very
much thanks for tuning in see you soon
peace
hey my body is shaking